[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
herzlich willkommen im neuen Jahr wir
starten heute mal direkt mit einem
schönen herzhaften Rezept was nur 15
Minuten eurer Zeit benötigt denn viel
Feedback kamen Laptop habe ich noch an
hoppala das waren die Weihnachtsferien
ich sag's euch ich habe einfach
vergessen Feedback von euch ist ihr
wollt mir einfache Rezepte Rezepte die
man eben ganz schnell zubereiten kann
gerade wenn man am Abend nach der Arbeit
zu Hause ist oder nach der Schule nach
der Uni was auch immer deswegen gibt's
heute eine
15-minuten-pfanne Gnocchis jetzt habe
ich selber die Gnocchi das ist schon
Plural die mache ich jetzt nicht selber
sondern das ist quasi aus dem Kühlfach
und alles andere was ich hier habe ist
auch aus meinem Tiefkühlfach das heißt
das ist ein Rezept wo ihr wirklich die
Zutaten immer zu Hause haben könnt und
vielleicht reden wir auch mal drüber
einfach einen was brauche ich in meinem
Kühlschrank Gefrierschrank und
Vorratsschrank Video zu machen
um immer über die Runden zu kommen so
mit Essen und Trinken was man halt immer
so da hat um schnell kochen zu können da
muss man nicht immer jeden Tag einkaufen
gehen können wir gerne mal machen
schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare
jedenfalls zeige ich euch die Zutaten
und sagt gleich was dazu dafür verwende
ich etwas Olivenöl eine Knoblauchzehe
und Zwiebel etwas Paprika Paste oder
Paprika mag dann habe ich hier etwa 200
ml Wasser 2 Esslöffel gemüsebrühpaste
500 g ist eine fertige Packung 200g
Erbsen aus dem TK natürlich Salz und
Pfeffer mit Zitrone zum Abschmecken
einen Esslöffel Dill der ist schon
getrocknet 400 g Lachs aus dem
Tiefkühlfach
750g Spinat aus dem Tiefkühlfach und 100
g Sahne also die Zutaten müssen jetzt
nicht aufgetaut werden das einzige was
jetzt aufgetaut habe aber nicht auch das
muss nicht sein ist der Spinat den habe
ich kurz in die Mikrowelle gepackt und
falls ihr den Spinat nicht auftauen
lassen wollt sondern direkt aus dem TK
nimmt spart ihr euch eigentlich auch das
Wasser denn spinat ist immer voll mit
extrem viel Wasser ist irgendwie immer
ein bisschen muss ich sagen eine
Mogelpackung weil die glaube ich den
Spinat Tropf nass reinpacken ganz viel
Wasser rein und von 750 Gramm spinat ist
das hier übrig und das ganze Wasser habe
ich einfach weggeschüttet jetzt geht es
hier ganz schnell denn ihr erhitzt
einfach schon mal eure Pfanne mit
Olivenöl
und solange die warm wird mache ich
jetzt auf Mittel hoher Hitze kann ich
schon mal die Knoblauchzehe und die
Zwiebel fein schneiden
dann gibt ihr die Zwiebel und
Knoblauchwürfel hier rein und bratet sie
einfach schon mal an ich gebe da auch
immer gerne den Deckel drauf dann rechts
zu Hause nicht so sehr nach Zwiebeln
[Musik]
und dann kann ich schon mal den Lachs
schneiden und der lässt sich tatsächlich
am besten schneiden wenn er noch gar
nicht so arg aufgetaut ist
dann kann man schöne Würfel schneiden
und ich mag es nicht so gerne wenn es zu
Hause noch Fisch riecht deswegen brate
ich den nicht mit an sondern lege ihn
später einfach mit in die Soße dann wird
er quasi so gegart ohne Röstaromen aber
ich finde das braucht man beim Lachs
auch gar nicht also der muss nicht
zwingend angebraten werden finde ich
einfach schöne große Würfel
wenn die Zwiebeln etwas angebraten sind
gebt ihr auch das Paprikamark dazu ihr
könnt auch gerne Tomatenmark natürlich
nehmen und ich habe Paprika Mark und
Tomatenmark auch immer im Tiefkühlfach
weil ich oft so ein großes Glas kaufen
und fasziniert es dann in meine
Eiswürfelbehälter dann habe ich immer so
eine Portion deswegen sieht es immer so
lustig wie so ein kleiner Würfel aus und
dann gebe ich noch die Gemüsebrühe dazu
und kann eigentlich schon alles mit
Wasser aufgießen
und dann lasst ihr das hier aufkochen
und gebt jetzt alle Zutaten rein also
die Gnocchi dann den Lachs wenn ihr
keinen Lachs mögt könnt ihr zum Beispiel
auch Hähnchen nehmen oder das ganze auch
weglassen die Erbsen finde ich immer
ganz gut wenn ihr noch Gemüse im
Kühlschrank habt packt es auch mit rein
und gern auch direkt den Spinat denn
dann habt ihr alles in einer Pfanne pack
den Deckel drauf und dann darfst erstmal
durchgaren
[Musik]
direkt die Sahne drauf und verrührt
alles schon mal gut
[Musik]
dann würzt ihr schon mal alles mit Salz
und Pfeffer und je nachdem wie viel
Wasser im Spinat ist kann es sein dass
sie entweder noch ein bisschen Wasser
benötigt oder eben nicht da schaut ihr
einfach gleich in den Topf rein Dill
gebe ich jetzt noch dazu weil es
hervorragend dazu passt und natürlich
dürft ihr auch wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt
ein bisschen cremige haben einfach eine
komplette Packung Sahne dazugeben also
auch das ist erlaubt und Zitronensaft
passt perfekt zum Fisch und eben auch
perfekt so zum ganzen Rezept
jetzt alles gut verrühren Deckel drauf
geben und dann darf das so etwa 8 bis 10
Minuten durchziehen immer mal wieder
durchrühren ich räume so lange auf und
dann probieren wir es gleich
ich war noch nicht so aufgeregt
beruhig dich ich mache dieses Jahr bei
Let's Dance mit yay und ich darf's euch
endlich sagen ich habe gerade das Video
glaub fünf oder sechs mal angefangen
weil ich jedes Mal weinen muss ich freue
mich schon richtig auf die Zeit ich
freue mich auf die ganzen Tänze die ich
lernen werde denn momentan als ich tanzt
zwei hin und wieder mal also ich meine
kennt mich ja nein dies Partys wir
machen hier Karaoke und Gesang wird
tanzen durch die Küche aber so richtig
tanzen kann ich nicht deswegen möchte
ich das unbedingt lernen und ich freue
mich einfach dabei zu sein das heißt ab
dem 17 Februar das die große
kennenlernen Show ich weiß noch nicht
wer mitmacht ich weiß noch nicht wer der
Tanzpartner wird aber ich weiß am 17
februar geht's los das ganze wird live
sein und wenn ich es bis zum Finale
schaffe was ich natürlich sehr hoffe
werde es bis zum 19 Mai jeden Freitag
Abend und ich werde klassische Tänze
lernen ich muss ganz hart trainieren
denn ihr kennt mich ich bin keine
Sportkanone auch wenn ich es immer mal
wieder probiere ich freue mich auf alles
was ich lerne ich freue mich auch schöne
Kostüme ich freue mich auf Euch wenn Ihr
Teil meiner wenn ihr also als meine
Community Teil der Show werdet und dann
für mich anruft ich bin einfach schon
gespannt drauf wie es sein wird für mich
wird es natürlich ganz krass weil ich
dann einfach diese Wochen die ich dort
sein werde zu Hause zwar trainiere mit
meinem Tanzpartner hier vor Ort und
wirklich zu Hause bin zwei Tage in der
Woche bin ich dann in Köln und ich freue
mich einfach darauf weil es mal was
anderes wird es wird eine große
Herausforderung und ich glaube ich habe
in meinem Leben schon viel gemeistert
ein Unternehmen aufgebaut die Kinder mit
großgezogen mit dabei und ich war noch
nie so aufgeregt wie jetzt in meinem
Leben und ich habe echt die letzte
Stunde glaube 20 Mal geweint weil ich
noch nicht so ganz drauf klar komme dass
ich bei Let's Dance dabei bin und
manchmal lege ich nachts wach weil es
mir einfällt und nicht mehr denke okay
krass es ist soweit also seid gerne mit
dabei ich hoffe ihr freut euch genauso
sehr wie ich und schaltet unbedingt
Freitag Abend ein ein mein Gott und ruft
ist für mich denn bei Let's Dance ist
ganz wichtig ich bekomme eine
jurorenbewertung natürlich von den drei
Juroren aber die Community ist ganz
wichtig das heißt ich brauche wirklich
eure Unterstützung bitte ruft du mich an
oder schreibt SMS damit ich weiterkomme
denn ich will unbedingt weiterkommen und
unbedingt das Maximale aus mir rausholen
und tanzen lernen ja
ich glaube einfach das wird die Zeit
meines Lebens denn
die letzten zehn Jahre habe ich viel in
der Küche gemacht und jetzt freue ich
mich drauf dass ich tot nämlich heute
schon wieder
guckt euch einfach an und macht mit okay
ich freue mich
[Musik]
und fertig ist unser Gericht also
natürlich noch schön mit Salz und
Pfeffer abschmecken wenn ihr wollt gerne
noch Käse rein Parmesan drauf was auch
immer ihr möchtet ich muss sagen
Tiefkühler Spinat sieht nicht ganz so
lecker aus wie frischer Spinat aber ich
finde es trotzdem immer gut weil wir uns
da hat heute darf ja probieren
[Applaus]
probieren und dann schon mal
anschließend einfach schön Abendessen ja
was gibt's heute leckeres Spinat Lachs
Gnocchi mit Erbsen alles Zutaten die ich
zumindest immer da habe aber vielleicht
die meisten auch in Zukunft so im
Vorderrad in im Tiefkühler Zutaten die
du immer hast ja so tiefgefrorenes
Gemüse ich habe immer gern Brokkoli da
das esse ich immer gerne könnte man ja
hier auch alternativ
genau
und immer so so Passat machen gerne
oder so also ja und wenn ihr dann noch
ein bisschen Gemüsebrühe habt und etwas
mit Rahmen also entweder Sahne saure
Sahne Schmand
cremefrei Frischkäse da kann man
eigentlich immer sowas machen auf jeden
Fall ja das kann einfach
um so richtig Hunger heute
boah richtig lecker
und ich finde immer so Gemüse mit rein
das ist schon
mach jetzt hier 500 Gramm Gnocchi und
ich finde das ist halt schon krasser
Sattmacher aber ich versuche immer dann
so Beilagen oder halt so Zutaten mit
dazu zu nehmen wie Spinat Gemüse was
gesundes Lachs das nur noch einfach
viele Vitamine zu sich nimmt ohne eben
nur eine schupfnudelpfanne oder eine
Gnocchi Pfanne oder Nudelpfanne mit zu
wenig Zutaten die einen auch Nährstoffe
geben
ja richtig lecker ja also wir essen das
jetzt und ihr schreibt mir gerne ob ihr
weitere solche Rezepte haben wollt ich
muss immer dazu sagen dass dann können
so Sterne Essen ne das ist nichts
passiert irgendwo auf einer Karte
bestellt aber das ist was ich esse gerne
abends oder mittags es geht schnell easy
Zutaten günstig einfach zusammen würfeln
alles rein one Pot perfekt ja schreibt
mir gerne mal ob ihr weiterhin solche
Rezepte sehen wollt ich hole jetzt noch
Murat und die Kids Team ist er schon da
bin ich mit und das nehme ich mit bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]